labor secretary Eugene Scalia he joins
us live from the DC area good morning to
you mr. secretary good morning good to
be with you you know yesterday I spoke
on the phone with Kansas labor secretary
Garcia and you know this strikes
everybody her family down Wichita has
had a restaurant there for decades
they're closed everything you know
everybody is on unemployment the state
of Kansas is you know has a very low
rate of unemployment on a regular week
maybe 1300 would apply over the last
week 55,000 apply they had to quadruple
the the call center it is all hands on
deck at the state level as well as the
federal level to make sure that the
people who file unemployment can get
their money and ultimately get the
stimulus as well right yes the states
are working very hard to get these
payments out as you know one of the key
provisions in the cares Act which the
President signed two weeks ago was this
enhancement to unemployment compensation
benefits there that are ordinary
ordinarily made available by the states
it's additional $600 a week that's being
made available and the states are
working very hard to to make that money
available I think now seven states are
making that available to people who've
lost work as well as 2gig economy
workers independent contractors aren't
ordinarily eligible for unemployment
compensation but this legislation that
the president moved through Congress and
does make it available for them to mr.
secretary talked about the bounce-back
we heard the president yesterday saying
we will the economy will turn around do
you agree with him and how are we gonna
do that what will I do agree and I share
that optimism these are such challenging
times for workers and their families and
we recognize that the program that we
were just talking about is one
reflection of the efforts here in
Washington to address it but at the same
time I'm mindful of just how strong our
economy was five weeks ago you know at
the start of March we put out one of the
strongest jobs reports we've seen in
this country in 50 years
that's where we were and that's where we
want to get back to as I mentioned last
night when I spoke at the briefing we
had a blue-collar boom and and now we
want a blue-collar bounce back and I
think that we still have the
fundamentals there our economy is
hurting now not because of an underlying
weakness in the economy but because of a
health emergency so we need to tackle
that and you have been so good at urging
your viewers to take these measures to
beat the virus but then we do want to
get back to work
and I think we have the foundation the
fundamental and the presidential
policies in place to be optimistic about
that about that recovery so mr.
secretary we see Denmark begin to get it
back online
Austria get back online Germany get back
online Taiwan is back online
Singapore's back online are you studying
those countries to see how to do it even
though we're so much bigger and with
such diverse such diversity are you
where she would model are you looking at
on for Americans getting back to work
well we're certainly looking at what
other countries have done and we're
looking at what this country has done in
the past too you know we look back 100
years ago
dealing with the Spanish flu there
lessons to be learned there we know a
couple of things first that discipline
right now remains extremely important we
know that we will need to get back
before this virus is entirely gone from
among us and we have to plan for that we
know it might not be the same date in
every location that we're we're all back
to work we'll need to plan accordingly
but we also know that we can't wait too
long we want to bounce back that does
get harder the longer that that people
are kept from work and we have to keep
that in the balances were absolutely
sure and as labor secretary you know you
know that a lot of people want to get
back to work as quickly as possible
and regarding that story in The
Washington Post this morning that
apparently the administration the
president in particular would like to
have essentially American business
reopened
maybe in stages by May 1st but there are
going to be hot spots it can't
one-size-fits-all yep we're open for
business again can you explain as much
as you can about what's going on behind
the scenes to get us to that place well
obviously there are a number of
different components to this that the
health component and Public Health
Policy is is critical to get right the
measures that have been put in place to
tide workers over are so important to
them individually the Paycheck
protection program which you talked
about a moment ago for a small business
is one of the things in this recent
legislation that I like most because not
only does it provide income to workers
during this difficult time it keeps them
tied to their employer so that when
we're ready to reopen that relationship
still exists that that's something we've
been talking about obviously there's an
interest in extending that program and
then we're talking about the health and
welfare of people when they return to
work that is something that we're going
to have to look after it's important to
us now at the Labor Department and as we
reopen we're going to want to make sure
that it's an environment that's safe and
healthy mr. secretary there was a
headline this morning saying some folks
some Americans are gonna get those
stimulus checks today can you update us
on on when people will get that money
well there are a couple of different
streams of relief coming first there is
as I just mentioned the Paycheck
protection program and there's more than
I think 140 billion in loans already
approved through that program and those
loans are now being made available to
small businesses right and that will
continue over time then we have the
payments coming from the Internal
Revenue Service and I believe that those
will be coming next week is what
secretary minuchin has said and then
finally there are these stepped-up
unemployment insurance payments going to
people who unfortunately are out of work
those already have started in some
states and we'll have more states coming
online in the days and weeks ahead and
mister labor secretary I know this
mostly Treasury
but you put out that money for small
businesses and I know they're grateful
but you have to understand some of these
restaurants and health clubs the 7525
doesn't work out if they have to give
75% of the money to labour they're not
gonna have any money to pay their bills
and pay their rent and pay their lease
and pay for equipment that they rent so
if the money's there there's got to be
flexibility given to the banks to allow
small business to use it because right
now if they're gonna put all that money
to labour they're not going to have a
business to go back to so do you see
that do you see some flexibility there
well I think that the Treasury
Department and the Small Business
Administration which have been running
this program have shown a lot of
flexibility there were some adjustments
to the application form made early on
that made it easier for people to apply
I just think the program has been
functioning extraordinarily well its
biggest challenge has been really its
popular not in those two areas these
restaurant owners these restaurant
owners can't live with 75% going to
labor many of these people don't want
their part-time jobs back so you can't
give them the money tell them to give
them the people that don't want the jobs
and then ask them to keep the lights on
and turn up with a diminished seating
capacity when they come back it's not
gonna work well we'll keep looking for
the right balance there and as you say
the Small Business Administration
treasurer are running that program from
my perspective as a Labor Department
those relationships with workers and
poising our companies the businesses to
come back but also to have those workers
still tied to them and keeping those
strong relationships is really going to
be very important to getting the Comedie
economy going again alright it is great
to have the Secretary of Labor from the
United States mr. Scalia with us today
so thank you very much thank you thank
you